Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
So und reden wir heute wieder über den Elefanten im Raum.
Der Raum ist nicht mehr. Der Elefant hat fertig.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer zweihundertneun und jetzt bin ich wieder da.
Äh du einen kleinen Ausritt äh gemacht hast mit Konstanze in der letzten äh Sendung. Ja, so einen thematischen.
Ist da es war letztlich ja auch thematisch äh fokussiert. Ich fragte mich bloß die ganze Zeit,
meinte, wenn sie sagt, sie würde jetzt den Tim machen.
Das höre ich auch nicht ganz verstanden. Das hat sie mir erst nachher erklärt. Da haben wir gelacht. Laut gelacht.
Da freue ich mich natürlich, ob's ihr gelungen ist.
Ja, na, ich mache jetzt heute mal selber den Tim. Was auch immer das bedeuten mag.
Ich versuche mal die Konstanze. Ich äh versuche mal, die Konstanze.
Das können doch schwieriger werden. Ja.
Wie war denn dein Urlaub, Tim?
Ähm OK also ich hab's ja eigentlich nicht so mit Winterurlaub.
Ist äh Winterurlaub nur wenn dann in der Sonne, ne?
Also ich hab ich hab ja, ich hab nichts gegen Winterurlaub, äh, so Wittersport ist ja nicht so meine Abteilung.
Ach, bist du, hast du Winter gesportet? Haste nicht.
Nee. Nein, ich ich habe ich äh.
Möglichst ferngehalten. Aber andere Leute haben das getan.
Kannst du auch hier so einen Schlitten rodeln?
Ja ich äh ist interessant, dass dieser Vorschlag immer als erstes guckt. Das hatte ich auch tatsächlich erwogen. Allerdings wurde mir der äh ja, das äh.
Na ja, Schlitten, weil das halt was für doofe ist, ne? Oder nicht finden, ist nichts für doofe, aber das können auch doofe,
zweijähriges Kind, setzte auf einen Schlitten, siehst du dran, ziehst du an den Seil, so kann nicht viel passieren.
Ja, ich hatte äh eigentlich auch zuerst geplant, mich von irgendjemand über die Berge äh ziehen zu lassen, das hat, aber hat allerdings, hat allerdings nicht funktioniert,
Und als ich dann wirklich mit dem Schlitten äh mal tatsächlich den Berg runterfahren wollte, äh den aber vorher noch irgendwo abstellte an so einer äh Bergstation, war er dann schon geklaut, als ich dann dahin kam. Also von daher,
Ja, die habe ich gezockt.
Die wird natürlich grad neu gekauft hatten.
Ja
So viel dazu. Die Welt ist schlecht.
Ja, dann so ist natürlich bei dir vorm ersten Einsatz der Schlitten gezockt wird, ist der Winterurlaub halt mäßig.
Also sowas finde ich auch wirklich
Muss ich sagen, also da habe ich überhaupt auch nicht auch nur das geringste Verständnis alle, also ich selber kann den Verlust eines Schlittensäss noch verkraften, ne, aber wie das so auf die Kinder wirkt, das ist einfach mal keine keine keine schöne Sache, also was sowas macht man einfach nicht.
Also soll sollte der Dieb zufällig Lockbuchnetzpolitik hören? Das war bei meiner.
Schäm dich.
Ja irgendwie Fahrzeugdiebstahl ist eh prinzipiell uncool, also ist einfach Assi. Ich ich mir wurde auch mein Fahrrad geklaut. Also Diebstahl ist.
An sich an sich, an sich ist schon mal schlimm.
Diebstahl ist uncool. Diebstahl machen nur doofe. Sollen wir arbeiten gehen?
Gut. Das war's dann wieder mit der Kommen.
Komm. Das ist aber Netzpolitik äh äh reden.
Und äh über unsere Poppenheimer hier im Netz. Poppenheimer im Netz,
Gibt's ja äh auch welche, unter anderem äh Herr M. Herr M, ähm Herr M wird nicht zugeben.
Wehrt sich gerichtlich gegen die Behauptung. Nein, also.
Tatsächlich ein Fall der ähm der wirklich äh an dieser Stelle mal äh
Also der äh einen Konflikt zeigt, der gerade in dieser in unserer Gesellschaft wütet und der auch mit dem entsprechenden,
mit der entsprechenden Mehrperspektiven mehr Schichtigkeit betrachtet werden muss. Also es gibt einen jungen Mann namens Anas M. Ich glaube der ist aus Syrien nach Deutschland gekommen.
Und ähm hatte an irgendeiner äh ähm hatte vor ein paar Jahren als äh die Gelegenheit ein Selfie mit äh.
Berühmtes Foto mittlerweile.
Berühmtes Bild, weil eine äh hier.
Ne, die freuen sich, die danken da das irgendwie, hier läuft alles gut, wir schaffen das so, ne? Und natürlich auch ein äh ein ein Reizbild für äh ähm sogenannte.
Ähm Asylkritiker, weil es geht ja schon mal damit los, warum hat er ein Smartphone,
ne? Steht dem ja überhaupt nicht zu. So, damit damit geht's ja schon los, ne? Ähm außerdem, was macht er hier außerdem, warum kümmert sich Angela Merkel um den und so weiter? Ähm weil.
Äh für die Kurse Bemerkung finde ich immer interessant, ne, dass das so ein Smartphone der deutschen Gesellschaft immer noch so als Luxusartikel äh angesehen wird, also die Omnipräsenz dieser Geräte weltweit, die muss der muss man sich einfach bewusst sein.
Es ist vor allem also man ähm,
dieser dieser Smartphonesache liegt nämlich eigentlich was ganz anderes zu Grunde. Viele ähm Europäer gehen davon aus, dass die Geflüchteten, wenn die damit hundert Mann,
In der Gummifluppe sitzen ähm da drin sitzen,
weil sie kein Geld haben, nichts anderes hätten, um rüberzukommen. Das ist nicht der Fall. Ähm,
die haben nur keinen anderen Weg, denn ähm den wir,
sich ein äh.
Flugtickets zu kau.
Der Economy Class ähm zu kaufen,
in Ruhe hier rüber zu fliegen und sich dabei einen Anzug anzuziehen und ähm.
Im Internet zu surfen mit ihrem Smartphone. Nur das geht ja nicht. Das ist den ähm.
Quasi den Fluggesellschaften untersagt. Äh die Personen ohne Visum überhaupt zu befördern. Und ähm.
Ohne ähm die bekommen kein Visum, weil man, wenn sie ein Visum bekämen, dann kämen sie nach Deutschland und könnten hier Asyl beantragen. Das ist der Grund, warum man ihnen die jeglichen
ähm sicheren Möglichkeiten äh hier,
herüberzukommen, verwehrt, ja? Ähm,
die sitzen nicht in diesen Booten aus Armut, sondern weil es das äh sondern weil die da gehen auch sehr ein Vielfaches von einem äh Flugticket für aus für diese äh Selbstmord äh
Kapikaze äh reisen, die da ja bei denen die Überquerung des Mittelmeeres in einer Gummifluppe äh ja nur so, dass dass
Die letzte Hürde ist, die gehen auch durch irgendwelche Wüsten äh und und was nicht alles, ne?
Ja, aber selbst selbst, wenn die äh finanzielle Lage der einzelnen nicht so gut ist, ein Smartphone ist,
das erste, in das man überhaupt investiert, weil es einfach den besten Nutzungs,
Preis nutzen, Verhältnis aufweist, weil man einfach damit,
Die Kommunikation hat nebenbei eben auch noch äh Landkarten und eine anderes und das ist halt einfach mal mehr wert als vieles mehr wert als ein Auto, mehr.
Aber genau, ich wollte noch kurz bei der Gelegenheit noch darüber sprechen, äh kurz erwähnen, Podcastempfehlung. Ähm Metro
Metrolaut sechsundzwanzig Seenotrettung,
da habe ich das nämlich gelernt, als ich das gehört habe, dass sie äh wie das mit den Flugzeugen ist und mit der Sicherheit und so. Und da sind äh zwei Leute zu Gast, einmal
der Ruben Neugebauer und dann der,
Steini vom CCC ähm die sich äh damit mit auseinandersetzen, also die für Sea-Watch und äh Searchwing,
sich engagieren. Also ganz, ganz, ganz interessanter Podcast sei an dieser Stelle empfohlen. So, zurück zu dem Merkel-Selfie
Ähm der gute Anas M hat also dieses Selfie äh gemacht. Ähm das Bild davon, wie die beiden zusammen das Selfie machen, äh war dann irgendwie ging um die Welt und durch die sozialen Netzwerke. Und äh wird seitdem ähm
regelmäßig von fremdenfeindlichen,
Hetzern äh benutzt die so ungefähr bei jeder unziemlichen Straftat, die irgendwo stattfindet, äh die Facebook, äh die Fake News verbreiten. Er wäre gefäßen.
Ähm also irgendwie hätte Obdachlose angezündet, er wäre Terrorist, ähm.
Ihn mit mit jeder Straftat in Verbindung hätte, irgendwie ein Kalb äh auf dem Spielplatz geschächtet, irgend so ein Scheiß halt.
Mhm
Also ist auch kein neues Phänomen, das gibt's natürlich im Netz schon äh länger. Das ähm,
dass immer wieder mit der Unterstellung irgendjemand sei ein Terrorist et cetera äh einfach verwendet und verbreitet wird.
So, der wird also jetzt als als äh Terrorist,
ausführlich im Netz verleumdet und es hat auch irgendwie,
längst äh den den Rahmen des irgendwie noch amüsanten äh verlassen, ja? Ähm ziemlich übel, was dem.
Typen da wieder fährt, weil der natürlich dann auch die entsprechenden,
Reaktionen der Menschen, ne? Also mit der die Falschbehauptung oder das Anprangern von Personen,
immer nur der erste Schritt, was nämlich danach passiert an an
an Angriffen, die die Person dann nur noch so semiöffentlich oder gar nicht öffentlich bekommen
Bedrohung und derartigen das ist ja das was diese Hetzerei eigentlich so übel macht ja? Der aufgeklärte Teil der Gesellschaft weiß ohnehin, dass es sich bei den Leuten, die sowas schreiben, um Idioten handelt, ne? Das heißt, du hast da jetzt nicht wirklich einen Rufschaden, dadurch, dass dich irgend so ein klassischer Internethetzer
ähm an Pranger stellt, äh sondern du hast halt darunter zu leiden, was was dessen Gefolgschaft dann mit dir macht.
Ähm und da sagt er, äh sagt er jetzt, na ja, jetzt müssen wir äh dagegen muss ich mich,
äh zur Wehr setzen, ja? Ich äh möchte ähm.
Dass das aufhört ja? Und äh wenn jetzt verklagt ähm Facebook.
Sagt er möchte, dass äh diese ähm dass diese Verleumdung, also er möchte da Rechtssicherheit haben und er möchte, dass das aufhört.
Ähm,
sagt, sie haben nicht die Möglichkeit, solche verlorenderischen Posts automatisch zu entdecken.
Dass äh,
ich würde sagen, sie haben die Möglichkeit, nicht das mit hundertprozentig.
Mit hundertprozentiger Treffsicherheit automatisch zu erkennen, aber sie haben natürlich die technische Möglichkeit.
Genau und vor allem sie haben vielleicht noch nicht eine konkrete Implementierung eines solchen Features gemacht, aber es ist natürlich technisch sicherlich äh in vielerlei Hinsicht denkbar, also allein die Gesichtserkennung in den Fotos, die
wir alle wissen durchaus gut funktioniert,
Und äh man wird ja auch die ganze Zeit angeschrieben, wenn man irgendwo in einem Foto äh markiert wurde et cetera. Äh gut, äh das ist ja äh manuelle Markierung, aber diese automatische Gesichtserkennung könnte selbstverständlich,
einer relativ hohen Wahrscheinlichkeit zumindest eben das Bild als solches ähm,
finden. Also und auch noch gar nicht mal, gar nicht mal nur die Gesichtserkennung, sondern überhaupt die Bild ähnlichkeitserkennung.
Ähm aber Facebook wehrt sich natürlich dagegen ähm,
hier eine vollständige Maßnahme zu entfalten, weil er fordert nicht ähm nicht nur äh dass alle bisherigen derartigen Verleumdungen verschwinden.
Künftig keine mehr kommen.
Sondern künftig alle findet und löscht. So und ich meine prinzipiell ist.
Muss man jetzt erstmal sagen, das ist ein Anspruch, der denke ich,
Nachvollziehbar ist und wo wir auch alle sagen würden, das ist, ist auch richtig, ne? Wenn dieser Mensch einer fortwährenden
Verleumdungskampagne durch Fremdenfeinde ausgesetzt ist, dann hat er natürlich einen begründeten Anspruch darauf, dass es aufhört, ja? Und dass Facebook etwas dagegen,
tut. Ähm jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was kann Facebook dagegen tun? Und ähm.
Das Problem ist, wenn wir wären dann in so einem Bereich, der äh ja ähm.
Einer Privatisierten Rechtsdurchsetzung gewissermaßen. Facebook will natürlich vermeiden ähm.
Dass sie dazu verurteilt werden, so etwas tun zu müssen. Weil dann Tür und Tor in Anführungszeichen geöffnet wäre. Äh nee, Entschuldigung. Facebook will vermeiden,
dass es ein Urteil gibt, in dem ihnen prinzipiell gesagt wird, dass sie äh für Inhalte ähm Haf,
Denn der momentane rechtliche Stand ist ja,
kann jeder überall alles veröffentlichen und auch
auf deiner Plattform Dinge veröffentlicht werden. Ab dem Moment der Kenntnis jedoch von rechtswidrigen Inhalten haftest du und musst sie dann entfernen. Das bedeutet aber für unseren äh Freund Anas M, dass er im Prinzip den ganzen Tag auf Facebook sitzen müsste.
Und nach diesem Bild und nach sich selber suchen müsste und Facebook melden müsste hier schon wieder, schon wieder schon wieder und dann Facebook immer sagen Mister ay yo, a yo, a yo.
Genau.
Äh oder keine durchsetzbar, also keine sinnvolle Möglichkeit dieser Verleumdungskampagne, die so vielschichtig ist und von so vielen Leuten her vorangetrieben wird, Einheit zu gebieten.
Ne, kannst jetzt nicht einen Menschen, der jeden Tag Ziele einer verloren muss. Kampagne ist sagen, ja, du musst jetzt halt die ganze Zeit auf Facebook lauern und gucken, wo wo du überall verläumet wirst und uns das melden
ja? Insofern ist schon sehr verständlich, dass er sagt, nee Freunde, also da müsst ihr jetzt mal irgendwie was machen.
Das Problem ist, was Facebook machen könnte, wären also,
Upload-Filter, ne? Also Facebook kann gerade bei den Bildern natürlich sofort erkennen, dass es dieses Bild ist,
Ne, das ist eine triviale Aufgabe ähm auch Ähnlichkeiten zu diesem Bild oder Ausschnitte von diesem Bild zu erkennen und zu sagen, nee, sowa
Gib es dieses Bild gibt es hier bei Facebook einfach nicht mehr. Wer dieses Bild hier hochlädt, das wird einfach vollständig gesperrt,
ähm oder ein,
Post, der dieses Bild beinhaltet, wird sofort irgendwie einer weiteren Kontrolle zugeführt, was weiß ich,
so 'ne Face Fake News Kontrollstelle aufbauen.
Ja, man muss dazu sagen, vor allem gibt es das auch schon,
Also ich meine, sie haben ja ihre ihre Nippel äh Filter auf der einen Seite, also sie sind ja immer äh sehr hinterher, was so die äh Abbildung von äh primären, weiblichen Geschlechtsorganen betrifft so, ja, während ja die anderen äh Nippel, der Männer sind ja irgendwie nicht so äh schlimm
Hast du diese diese geile Nippel Posting, Welle auf Facebook äh mitbekommen, wo sozusagen nur noch so Close U,
Nippelclose Ups gepostet wurden, die man nicht mehr unterscheiden könnte, ob sie jetzt männlich oder weibliche äh Nippel sind, damit äh,
wo sie das schon mal schön karikiert, Nippel geht und ähm ja das
es gibt da halt auch größere Teams. Ich weiß nicht genau, wo die sitzen. Indien, was weiß ich wo, die halt tatsächlich eben auf Facebook äh Posts auf,
Gewalt und Porno hin untersuchen. Also es ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass diese,
diese Mechanismen nicht schon in irgendeiner Form da werden, die Frage ist nur wer darf sie äh äh also.
Wissen, Wissen wer ist Herr über über das, ja? Ist das sozusagen nur Facebooks interne Policy oder kann eben dieses Instrument auch genutzt werden, um,
anderer Länder und anderer Herren Policis umzusetzen und egal wie sehr das durchautomatisiert ist es findet eben derzeit schon äh äh statt und die große Frage ist natürlich jetzt,
Kann man so ein Netzwerk dazu zwingen? Sollte man ein Netzwerk dazu zwingen, solche Mechanismen.
Und Face.
Oder in die in die Rechtssprechung zu kommen.
An die Rechtsprechung und vor allem vor allem, es wäre eben, ne, es würde eben weitergehen, weil wenn du wenn du dieses Problem.
Effektiv für ähm.
Für die Gesellschaft als solche dauerhaft lösen möchtest, dann sagst du einfach Facebook haftet für Verleumdungen, fertig,
Und dann werden die sich entsprechend bemühen müssen da nichts reinzurasseln, ne? Das heißt, sie müssten dann eben ähm.
Die entsprechenden Maßnahmen ähm ergreifen, damit sie
Damit ihnen das nicht mehr passiert. Ähm mit anderen Worten, das ist das, was äh Markus Beckerdal auch in seinem Vortrag beim dreiunddreißig C drei,
als privatisierung der Rechtsdurchsetzung genannt hat,
da haben wir nämlich dann dieses ähm dieses Problem
das, das Recht schon durchgesetzt wird, gesprochen wird ähm.
Bevor es zum Tragen kommt, nämlich in dem Fall Facebook würde ähm äh vor äh zensieren quasi, ne? Also Facebook käme dann in die ähm in die Situation.
Selber diese Entscheidung zu treffen, was ähm äh Verleumdungen oder was Recht ist und was Unrecht ähm und zwar.
Mit im Rahmen einer Entscheidung, wo,
Fehlentscheidung, einerseits.
Hieße, dass sie haften, dass sie das bezahlen müssen und in die andere Richtung eine Fehlentscheidung hieße, dass sie eben einen legitimen Inhalt wegzensieren, obwohl er nicht verleumderisch ist. Und es wäre natürlich.
Klar, dass es im ökonomischen Interesse Facebooks läge,
als den Fehler zu machen, dass sie zu wenig löschen. Gleichzeitig im im prinzipiellen Interesse Facebooks wäre ähm
nicht zu viel zu löschen. Das heißt, für die wäre es einfach ein weiterer Kostenpunkt, ja.
Nicht nur eben die Fehler auszubaden und dafür zu bezahlen, sondern eben auch die,
bereitzustellen, um diese Entscheidung zu treffen. Das heißt, das wollen die auf jeden Fall vermeiden. Die wollen, wenn überhaupt ein Einzelfallentscheidungen, aber die haben Angst vor dem wegweisenden Urteil. Ja, wo sie dann ihre existenten Upload-Filter ähm
auf Meinungsäußerungen und Fake News anwenden müssen,
und das ist ein Konfliktfeld, was wir wahrscheinlich so einfach nicht aufgelöst bekommen. Ja, wir wollen wir äh wollen, denke ich nicht, dass derartige Verleumdungen dort stattfinden,
Gleichzeitig wissen wir, was die strukturelle Antwort auf Diesel oder die strukturelle Lösung für ein neues Problem wäre,
Nämlich die Errichtung einer ja der Begriff wird oft benutzt, eben einer Zensurinfrastruktur.
Und ähm man kann nur hoffen.
Dass die Gerichte da die Gefahr erkennen und irgendwie einen Mittelweg finden, der es einerseits Anas M ermöglicht, ähm.
In Frieden weiterleben zu können.
Andererseits aber ähm die,
zukünftigen Möglichkeiten der freien Meinungsäußerung auf Facebook.
Weiterhin bereit hält.
Ich meine, es gibt ja manches jetzt nicht,
falsch mitbekommen habe, allen dieser ganzen Debatte ja eigentlich auch zwei Diskussionsstränge, wo wir jetzt.
Die ganze Zeit geredet haben, ist dieses Blocken automatisch blocken oder halbautomatisch,
blocken, dass eben diese Nachrichten gar nicht erst entstehen,
äh Verbreitung, weil sehr wohl könnte man ja mit diesem selben Werkzeugen auch äh herausfinden,
Wer hat es denn ursprünglich gepostet? Also es ist innerhalb von Facebook natürlich
überhaupt gar kein Problem von einer beliebigen Nachricht mal eben den Ursprungsposter
herauszufinden, also wenn sie behaupten, das ginge nicht, das glaube ich ihnen einfach mal gar nicht.
Ich frage mich, ob das äh stattfindet, ob das äh nicht eher auch Teil der Diskussion sein sollte, weil in dem Moment, wo eben Leute, die das tun, eben auch konsequent äh.
Angeklagt verurteilt. Auf jeden Fall erstmal unter Umständen auch auf Facebook gesperrt werden.
Ähm wäre das ja einerseits auch im Sinne von Facebook oder sollte es zumindest äh sein und es eben auch sehr viel mehr im Sinne von
der eigentlichen Rechtsdurchsetzung, weil es zeigt sich ja auch immer wieder, dass die Leute, die das machen, sich natürlich dadurch auch vor allem motiviert fühlen, dass sie einfach schlicht und ergreifend niemand auf die Finger klopft dafür,
So und äh in dem Moment, wo du dann halt wirklich mal zu Hause äh bei denen auftauchst und an der Tür klingelst und sagst, guten Tag, äh ist das ihr Post,
Kommen sie mal mit. Ja, wir haben da einen schönen, einen schönen Satz. Kabelbinder für sie.
Ähm dann überlegen die sich das dann vielleicht eben auch äh,
zweimal, ob das nicht, aber das findet ja auch nicht statt. So, das äh finde ich Merkelchen. Hier haben wir dann wiederum diese Diskussion der Auskunftspflicht, ne? Inwiefern ist Facebook gezwungen an der Stelle Personalien rauszugeben.
Ähm muss man vielleicht prinzipiell nochmal sagen, dass.
Das Konzept der,
der freien Meinungsäußerung dann doch sehr viel.
Weiter interpretiert wird als vielleicht in Deutschland. Also sie sagen auch, ja, so eine Verleumdung und so, es ist im Zweifelsfall nicht okay, aber die haben sehr hohe ähm.
Sehr hohe Standards für freie Rede. Daher kommt auch, sage ich mal, dieser.
Gegen freie Räder habe ich ja auch überhaupt nichts einzuwenden, ne, nur die Interpretation, was was freie Rede ist, die ma,
äh sich unterscheiden und an der Stelle könnte man natürlich auch wiederum die die Grenzen da ziehen, wo sie
existieren, das heißt in dem Moment, wo die können ja in den USA diese freie Rede dann auch gerne bei Facebook ausüben, aber dieser Artikel muss ja nicht zwangsläufig dann auch in einem
deutschen Facebook-Zugang erscheinen, sondern kann an der Stelle schlicht und ergreifend scheitern
beziehungsweise wenn man da eben sagt, okay, was ist die Quelle und man merkt so, ah ja okay, das ist zwar jetzt hier deutscher Inhalt, aber das kommt dann auch aus irgend so einem Beratbar, Breitbart, Spinner auf den USA oder auf den Kämen Islands oder was weiß ich, in Russland oder so sitzt
dann kann man das zwar vielleicht nicht juristisch äh verfolgen beziehungsweise da nichts Juri,
kompatibles an Adressen und äh Ansprechpartnern generieren, aber man könnte zumindest sagen, okay, äh ihr dürft jetzt sozusagen eure Nachrichten gar nicht mehr,
nach Deutschland verbreiten, einfach als Sperre. So, dann äh erledigt sich das Problem in gewisser Hinsicht auch erstmal vorübergehend zu müssen. Bis neue Wege gefunden sind darum herum.
Also ich denke, das werden auch alles Maßnahmen, über die man zumindest debattieren soll. Ich habe da jetzt auch keine äh gute Lösung dafür und das ist auch glaube ich ein Dilemma, in dem wir uns jetzt hier generell befinden. Man sieht eben die berechtigten Proteste der Betroffenen.
Und man äh mag auch Verständnis aufbringen für die,
anderen Kontroll äh Möglichkeiten,
und Verbotsmöglichkeiten für ein Tor geöffnet wird, die wir dann,
auch nicht haben wollen, wo man dann natürlich ab wieder abwägen muss, was was ist, was wiegt schwerer, ja? Also die Not des Einzelnen, ja, oder die ähm,
die Angst aller an langfristigen, negativen Konsequenzen daraus.
Lösung gibt, die einerseits hohe ähm.
Rechtliche Standards an eine derartige Forderung bindet andererseits eine relativ schnelle.
Durchsetzung der Forderung, ja? Und eben möglichst bitte unter Beteiligung von,
einer äh Justiz und nicht unter Beteiligung von,
Facebook
wir machen das mal nach gut Dünken, sondern einer einer Regelung, die irgendwo,
ja juristisch gebackt ist, ne.
Was wäre das, zum Beispiel ein
Administrativ höher priorisierter Nutzerzugang für Law-Inforcent, die sozusagen so Polizeistreifen auf Facebook, die mit anderen Werkzeugen arbeiten können, als das normale Nutzer machen, vielleicht nicht derselbe Umfang
den Facebook hat, ich meine, das ist natürlich genauso problematisch.
Du willst keine, du willst keine äh du willst natürlich kein Schnellzugriff von deut.
Von den Gerichten, aber zumindest von der Polizei.
Ein noch schlimmer. Also ich denke, es wäre schon gut, wenn wenn da eine Richter, wenn da ein Richtervorbehalt gelte, bevor irgendwelche weitreichenden äh ähm Lösch-und Zensurmaßnahmen in sozialen Netzen äh implem.
Da weiß ich nicht, weil wie.
Na ja, ich meine, wenn wenn Facebook sozusagen nicht diese Information liefert, wer ist denn der Ursprung dieses Artikels? Ja. Ich weiß, es ist alles äh.
Das ist auch übrigens das, ich verstehe, also es gibt ein da noch ein weiteres Problem. Ähm.
Und das ist, ist diese Frau, ist die Verbreitung denn wirklich bösartig?
Also ist das strafbar, wenn ich irgendwo Misslese und den weitergebe, ne? Der, der, den Ursprung einer Behauptung, tja, ist wahrscheinlich auch schwer. Also.
Wir haben jetzt eine Anzeige gibt, muss dem zumindest schon mal nachgegangen werden. Also gibt es ja sozusagen ein ein Anfangsverdacht und einen Ermittlungsgrund und dann äh kann man auch aktiv werden.
Ich weiß nicht. Also wir haben, wir haben jetzt sozusagen kein, keine Empfehlung. Aber wir äh präsentieren das Ganze als Dilemma.
Es wird am siebten März, wird das Dilemma aufgelöst werden, angekündigterweise, da ist eine Entscheidung zu erwarten.
Von wem.
Dem Gericht. Ich habe leider mir jetzt gerade nicht gemerkt, auf welches Gericht das genau ist.
Okay.
Ganz kurz herausfinden.
Wir schauen mal, ja. Richtig erstrit.
Du hast auch Gericht. Äh ich finde jetzt auf Anhieb nicht welches Gericht das ist, aber wir werden es äh wir werden es dann spätestens bei der Verkundung.
Das Gericht.
In dem Artikel, den ich verlinkt habe, es gibt ja hunderte dazu. Nein.
Das jüngste Gericht.
Kommen wir zum nächsten jüngsten Gericht.
Genau. Das jüngste Gerücht.
Das ähm.
Social Bots, ja. Ich muss das immer noch erzählen, ist jetzt schon einige Zeit her, dass es eben diese äh dass die Social Bots, die den deutschen Bundestag äh,
beschäftigt haben. Da gab es einmal eine Sachverständigenanhörung.
Eine vom Ausschuss für,
Bildung und Technik folgen, Abschätzung in Auftrag gegebene Studie äh des Büros für Technik folgen, Abschätzung, die dann durchgeführt wurde vom VD IVDE ähm oder ja ähm,
bei der ersten Anhörung im Bundestagsausschuss digitale Agenda ähm war,
Unter anderem Markus Reuter von Netzpolitik Orgdort, aber auch,
wenn ich mich nicht täusche, der Christian Stöcker,
der inzwischen Professor in Hamburg ist und äh lange Zeit die Spiegel Online Netzwelt geleitet hat,
also Menschen die von dem Phänomen durchaus eine Ahnung haben,
Ähm und bei ich war also bei der äh ich war einer der insgesamt fünfundzwanzig
äh äh zu Rate gezogenen Sachverständigen bei für die Studie des Büros für Technik folgende Abschätzung
Und ähm warum haben die sich mit diesem Thema Social Bots so weit auseinander so viel auseinandergesetzt? Weil, ja, immer wieder die Rede davon ist, dass ja ähm die Wahlen äh ne auf diese Weise manipuliert wurden. Das ist also eine politische Einflussnahme gibt.
Mittels äh Social Bots und dass diese äh eine Gefahr für die Demokratie sei. Also man finde,
tatsächlich immer wieder äh so,
die die Leute da beschäftigen. Jetzt gehen wir mal einen kurzen Schritt zurück ähm.
Social Bots sind tatsächlich jetzt kein neues Phänomen. Ne? Also es gibt die,
solange wie es diese sozialen Netzwerke gibt, insbesondere bei Twitter gibt es ähm eine Reihe an Bots. Ähm wir kennen irgendwie auch so so diese Scherzbots, ne, irgendwie,
Bot, der Ei, immer wenn man Berliner sagt, äh sagt, du meintest doch wohl Pfannkuchen, ähm aber der muss noch mit, der braucht noch ein bisschen.
Mehr Kontext sind.
Wir brauchen bisschen Feintuning, auch weil der äh bei jedem Berliner Polizisten Pfannkuchenpolizist draus machen möchte. Ähm.
Es gibt also eine eine ganze Reihe.
Das müsste man mal mit Wiener Würstchen und Frankfurtern irgendwie in einen Start bring.
Dann unterhalten die sich wie Siri und Alexa stundenlang. Nein, ich, nein, ich, nein, ich.
Stimmt, das kann man natürlich auch machen. Also ähm ein Social Bot letztendlich.
Netzpolitik der Twitter-Account postet ja auch äh alles automatisch, was hier irgendwie verpodcastet wird.
Das habe ich in der Anhörung auch gesagt, ja, dass äh dass äh also bei der der Linus Neum äh Ziffer auf Twitter ist übrigens auch ein ein Hybrid,
ein Hybridbot, der twittert nämlich auch die neuen Folgen von Lokbuch Netzpolitik automatisch.
Ja, ich weiß und du solltest es immer noch umstellen, dass das Maritweet ist. So, du pushst ja nur dein eigenes.
Ich würde jetzt sogar machen, aber ich weiß gar nicht, wer genau mit welchem Scheißdienst ich das diese Tweets ab Sonntag. Ich glaube, das ist irgendwie eben nicht beim Wert.
Äh sachdienliche Hinweise zu dieser technischen Frage.
Ja, ich könnte das auch mal äh ne, wenn ich schon Sachverständiger für Social Bods.
Kurzzeitig auch eine andere Lösung.
Könnte ich das auch mal, könnte ich da auch mal einen Pfeifens.
Ja. So ist das mit diesen sogenannten Experten, die da immer eingeladen werden. Am Ende keine Ahnung.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe selbstverständlich Betreiber auch ich mehrere Soc.
Social Bottfarmen.
Ich sage aber nicht welche. Nee, ist sie. Es macht Spaß.
Also, was ist ein Social Bot? Ein letztendlich ein,
Relativ simples äh Skript, den man
Aufgaben erteilt, die es dann in diesen sozialen Netzwerken erfüllt. Also zum Beispiel bestimmte Themen, Redviden oder den RSS-Feed von
von Logbuch Netzpolitik regelmäßig anschauen und wenn,
ein neues Item drin ist, äh dieses der Fettfietung
zuführen. Ähm also automatisiert Inhalte in soziale Netzwerke geben. Das kann man,
eben einfache, primitive Art machen, das kann man aber natürlich auch beliebig komplexer machen. Und äh was was ich als Phänomen ergeben hat, ist, dass es inzwischen eben sogenannte,
Armeen von Bots gibt. Ich nenne sie eher Herden, weil das nicht ganz so sehr nach,
Cyberware klingt. Äh also Herden an an Bots gibt, die,
man quasi als Meinungsmacher oder Meinungsvertreter.
In äh in Debatten geben kann und die zum Beispiel bei den Presidential Debails in den USA dann irgendwie äh
Trump One getwittert haben und irgendwie jeden der Clinton One getwittert hat irgendwie mit dem Link
beglückt haben, wo drin steht, Clinton ist gefährlich oder sowas, ne? Also man versucht sich quasi durch Masse und Automatisierung äh des Diskurses in den sozialen Medien,
zu bemächtigen.
Übrigens, der erste Fall weil es immer alle über den amerikanischen Wahlkampf reden, aber ich finde, man kann das an dieser Stelle auch nochmal erwähnen,
Oder der erste richtige Sündenfall in dieser Hinsicht war meiner Meinung nach diese Gamergate-Geschichte, die ja auch komplett aus der Hand gelaufen ist. Ähm auch da gab es nachweislich.
Ja solche Botfarben, die halt in diese Debatte mit eingegriffen haben.
Aber andererseits, ich meine, das gibt natürlich auch Stimmen, die meinen, das geht eigentlich dabei nur um äh Ethik in der Journalismus über. Gaming-Kultur, ne.
Ach so ja die der.
Ist das eine Gefahr für die Demokratie und werden so Wahlen manipuliert
Und ähm die Studie,
Büros für Technikfolgenabschätzung kommt, äh wenig überraschend zu dem sinnvollen Ergebnis,
das jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Emidid,
Gefahr für die Demokratie ist und dass es,
sehr unwahrscheinlich ist, ein Szenario zu konstruieren, in dem Social Bots ausgerechnet ähm Schuld daran sind, dass eine Wahl äh zu einem anderen Ergebnis gekommen ist
ja
es ist aber natürlich sinnvoll über das Phänomen der Social Bots aufzuklären, weil sie,
zum Beispiel für Follower zahlen oder der Anzahl an Pfaffsternchen, die ein Tweet hat, ähm
relevante Mengen an,
Numerischer Verzerrung herbeiführen können. Nur ob das jetzt eine Gefahr für die Demokratie ist, das wage ich Akt zu bezweifeln und äh diese äh Einstellung habe ich eben auch äh dort,
vertreten, wurde dafür tatsächlich von mehreren so ja.
Weil denen irgendwie nicht ganz klar war, weil die die Studie nicht gelesen hatten. Ja, in der eben auch drinsteht, dass das eigentlich nicht alle so
vertreten haben und dass die, dass das Berufetechnik folgende Abschätzung an dieser Stelle mit dieser Studie eben auch zu diesem Ergebnis kommt, dass das jetzt hier keine großartige Gefahr für die Demokratie ist und dass wir davon ausgehen können, dass auch in Zukunft die Wahlen noch
von den Wählern entschieden werden. Ein Beispiel was sich da,
genannt habe ist, ne? Wir haben seit sechzig Jahren in Deutschland die Bild-Zeitung,
Wir haben seit dreißig Jahren Privatfernsehen. Äh wir haben,
Millionen Ausgaben natürlich im Bereich der Wahlwerbung. Wir haben auch heute schon irgendwie Hahne, Büchen, Wahlplakate, äh bei jeder Wahl äh an den an den Masten hängen, ne? Und das ist jetzt sehr unwahrscheinlich.
Vor allem vor allem sehr weit oben.
Ja vor allem sehr weit oben hängt da äh,
allerlei Unsinn und es ist jetzt unwahrscheinlich das ausgerechnet Forscherbots jetzige neue Gefahr für die Demokratie sind.
Ist einfach äh,
unwahrscheinlich. Ähm vor allem wenn man sich dann mal das hatte, äh, auch Patrick Beuth schon in einem Artikel mal gemacht, einfach mal zu Grunde legt, wie viele Twitter-Nutzer gibt's denn in Deutschland, ja? Und da ist die, die Schätzung ist irgendwie zwischen ähm.
Zwischen ein und vier Millionen, ja? Und ähm! Was die Forscher, wenn ich da mal kurz sagen darf, was die Forscher da unlauterer Weise machen,
die es gibt da ein, zwei Forscher, die behaupten, ja das ist jetzt hier die große Gefahr für die Demokratie. Die nehmen Studien, äh die die führen Studien durch, in denen sie äh versuchen,
kurzfristige Effekte auf Einstellungen,
Also die messen dann sowas wie Aja, äh wenn die Leute hier in sozialen Netzen mit Meinungen XY konfrontiert werden, dann nähern sie sich dieser Meinung an.
Ja
Aber quasi, das sind kurzfristige Effekte, ja? Das heißt nicht, die haben jetzt einmal kurz auf Twitter ge,
Kannst du in der Psychologie regelmäßig nachweisen bekannte Effekte sind irgendwie,
ein eine Studie, die immer wieder zitiert wird ist Leute haben
in, haben ein, an einem psychologischen Experiment war teilgenommen, in den in der einen, die eine Hälfte hat einfach die ganze Zeit nur Bilder von alten Leuten bekommen und und Wörter, die mit alt sein und Vergänglichkeit äh connotiert sind.
Die anderen Leute haben irgendwie die ganze Zeit so dynamisch, jung und Sport äh gesagt bekommen. Und die abhängige Variable, also das, was gemessen wurde in dem ähm,
In dem äh in dieser Studie war, wie lange haben die nachher gebraucht.
Der Tür wo sie verabschiedet wurden bis zum Fahrstuhl.
Im Schnitt eine Sekunde länger gebraucht haben zum Fahrstuhl als die Leute, die ähm.
Die ganze Zeit Sportvisionen ein.
Ja? Das heißt aber nicht, dass diese Menschen für den Rest ihres Lebens langsamer gegangen sind, ja? Und zum Arsch ist heute.
Zum Fahrstuhl. Ich meine, wenn Sport ist.
Das gesamte Leben, die sind auch nicht früher gestorben.
Vor allem wenn wenn das wirklich äh einen Einfluss gehabt hätte mit dem Sport und wenn sie nicht zum Fahrstuhl gegangen sondern zur Trepp.
Ich, also.
Diese diese Ergebnisse, die es durchaus gibt, ne, die haben dann auch der der es ist natürlich die Werbung durchgedreht damals, ne, die haben dann auch so mit,
mit Subliminalen Reizen ähm irgendwie Coca Cola zu verkaufen und so.
Und so.
Das hat sich alles dann irgendwie in wohlgefallen aufgelöst, also du hast kurzfristige Effekte dessen, worüber du gerade nachdenkst, auf das, was du jetzt gerade tust, ja?
Klar und wenn dir gerade Argumente genannt wurden, die das andere sinnvoll erscheinen lassen,
nähert sich deine Position dem ein wenig an
und von einem dauerhaften Effekt, der jetzt irgendwie dazu führt, dass plötzlich eine Wahl manipuliert wurde, weil irgendjemand irgendwo dreihundertfünfzigtausend Social Bots hat. Sorry
wer sich ein bisschen mit mit Wissenschaft äh in diesem Bereich auseinandergesetzt hat, der weiß, dass das äh dem Lachtest nicht standhält,
Äh das habe ich auch so gesagt. Das war eben eine sehr prontierte Äußerung und äh deswegen habe ich auch den gesamten den gesamten Kram äh äh abbekommen von den von den Forschern, die halt damit jetzt gerade eine eine Karriere machen, ne.
Tja, Mensch. Wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt.
Wir haben, wir haben dieses Phänomen und es gibt zum Beispiel auch was, was was äh was überhaupt nicht da behandelt wurde. Ich hatte versucht, diese
Also in der in der in dem in der Studie kommt es vor was passiert ist, dass auch Leute fertig gemacht werden. Du kannst mit ein paar Social Boots
Ker, jemandem die Nutzung des äh seines Twitter äh äh seiner Twitter-App,
dauerhaft auf Dauer vergellen, ne? Wenn jetzt irgendwie äh sage ich mal dir dir dreihundertfünfzigtausend Social Bots mietest, ja.
Die kriegst du nicht weggeblockt.
Die Christe nicht weggeblockt. Und da wisst ihr, du wirst halt äh ne,
dann ist vorbei mit Twittern, dann kannst du äh die die Notifications abschalten,
kannst, kann ich die Rate hochschrauben, dann kriegst du halt fünf pro Minute und dann kannst du in deinen Menschens äh nichts mehr finden, ne? Also du kannst damit empfindlich Kommunikation stören, ja? Dass also aber solche Phänomene
wurden da.
Beziehungsweise wo es dann auch solche Mittel zurückgreifen, dass er sagt, ich will jetzt nur noch Menschens lesen von Leuten, die nicht folge und so und dann, ne? Ja, ist auf jeden Fall eine Einschränkung.
Fakt ist, die Leute äh die Politik überlegt sich.
Wie sie denn dieses Problem in den Griff bekommen, ja? Wohlwissend und deswegen musste man da auch mal mit dieser Studie das so klar machen, das ist hier kein Problem ist,
Das ist eine eine Herausforderung, vor der unsere Gesellschaft steht, vor der die Medienkompetenz, der mit der Leute steht. Das Problem, was wir haben.
Ist der Vertrauensverlust in Medien und Politik.
Und das ist es, warum Leute äh warum Trump Wahlsiege äh ermöglicht werden. Das ist es, warum ähm,
AfD Wahlerfolge zu erwarten sind
hier Anas M hat das und das gemacht
ne? Äh da muss man schon mal irgendwie äh die Phänomene äh die Ursachen und die Symptome ein bisschen auseinander halten,
Social Bots sind eben ein ein Phänomen und allenfalls ein Symptom und in keiner Form,
ursächlich für den Ausgang einer Wahl,
haben wir ganz andere Medien, äh die die eine sehr viel größere Wirkung entfa,
können. Ähm,
versuchen den Ausgang der Wahl zu äh beeinflussen.
Ja, bleibt aber trotzdem äh eine schwierige Debatte so, weil natürlich auch solche Dedos wie Hevia äh durchaus zu verurteilen ist, unabhängig davon, ob damit jetzt eine Wahl entschieden werden kann oder nicht,
Ja
Mal schauen. Wir werden auf jeden Fall allem, was äh sich die Bundestagswahl so äh in den Weg stellen kann in diesem Jahr.
Noch kurz zu diesem äh zu diesem Thema. Ähm die politischen Forderungen,
die da ursprünglich im Raume standen,
Waren ja irgendwie, was weiß ich, Verbot und äh äh Internet äh hier äh Personalausweispflicht im Internet und solche Sachen, die kommen ja dann immer wieder,
natürlich sofort hoch von äh äh von Seiten der ja, sagen wir mal der,
Hardliner und natürlich aus aus der CDU. Ähm wo die beheimatet sind. Diese Forderungen sind alle weg.
Es gibt jetzt noch so die halbwegs vertretbare und moderate Forderung der oder dem,
moderaten Vorschlag der Grünen, der lautet äh na ja dann mach doch eine Kennzeichnungspflicht, ne? Damit dann habt, haben wir einen Q, dann können Leute erkennen, ach okay, das ist hier kein Mensch, ne? Muss ich irgendwie rausfiltern. Ähm das ist ein Gedanke, der.
Ein Problem löst, was noch nicht unbedingt da ist, aber der im Zweifelsfall auch keinen Schaden anrichtet, ja. Insofern kann man da mal sagen, da ist ähm.
Diese Übertreibung des Problemes, wo der Übertragung des Problems wurde, durch diese Studie sinnvoll ähm Einhalt geboten und wenn die Politik jetzt unbedingt meint, da irgendetwas tun zu müssen.
Wie es eben der Fall ist, wenn ein Thema dauerhaft die Medien bestimmt, äh dann wäre dieser Vorschlag der Grünen da eben äh im Zweifelsfall der Vorschlag, der ähm keinen Schaden anrichtet. Und
Unter Umständen tatsächlich das Potential hat ähm.
Den Menschen die Orientierung in diesen sozialen Netz,
zu erleichtern.
Amen.
Schauen wir mal, was äh andere wissenschaftliche Studien äh gegebenenfalls für äh Folgende haben werden. Wir hatten ja hier schon vor einiger Zeit,
wieder berichtet, dass es äh neue Entscheidungen gab ähm,
EuGH,
Zum Thema Vorratsdaten, Speicherung in dem Fall ausgelöst von den entsprechenden gerichtlichen Vorgängen in Großbritannien und in Schwien, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere.
Nun gab's eine Anfrage des äh der Bundestagsfraktion, ja.
Linksfraktion ja.
Also Anfrage ist gut, keine keine Anfrage, also keine parlamentarische Anfrage, sondern ein Auftrag an den wissenschaftlichen Dienst, also es gibt ja diesen wissenschaftlichen Dienst, das hatten wir hier auch schon paar Mal, da gab's ja jetzt zuletzt auch die wegweisenden Entscheidungen, dass diese Ergebnisse grundsätzlich äh
auch öffentlich gemacht werden müssen und wenn halt Fraktionen solche,
Sachen in Auftrag geben, wozu sie quasi zwecks, also ich glaube quasi Fraktionsstatus ist es sozusagen, dass man als kann man den kann jeder Bundestags,
Geordnete, die ähm Anspruch nehmen oder können das nur Fraktion. Was ich jetzt nicht so ganz.
Die Linken dürfen das auf jeden Fall und haben's auch gemacht zum Thema Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Hatte der Muss auch Individuen zur Verfügung stehen, weil so hat er auch äh Guntenberg seine Doktorarbeit äh erstellen.
Ja, gut, aber ich meine, ist ja Teil einer Fraktion. Also das war,
wissen wir nicht, ne? Äh keine Ahnung. Also wenn's jetzt einen unabhängigen Kandidaten,
geben sollte oder eine sogenannte Gruppe im Bundestag, die kein Fraktionsstatus äh hat.
Also steht nochmal spezifisch unterstützen die Abgeordneten, ja? Also der.
Steht dem Abgeordneten, den Abgeordneten zur Verfügung.
Okay. Gut, gehen wir mal davon aus, es kann jeder beantragen. In diesem Fall waren's halt die Link,
was ist da jetzt bei rausgekommen? Ähm,
Der wissenschaftliche Dienst des Bundestages zieht die Regelung, also das aktuelle Gesetz,
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland ja in Zweifel,
weil es ähm offenbar nicht den äh Anforderungen des Bundesverfassungsgerichts.
Äh
EuGH.
Okay, also ist sozusagen jetzt eine Reaktion auf die äh neue Entscheidung des EuGH und hier wird dann im Wesentlichen festgestellt.
Dass äh der OGH ja gesagt hätte
findet sich in dem aktuellen Gesetz nicht, dass äh Anlose anlassloses Speichern,
geographisch nur auf eingegrenzte Gebiete beschränkt sein, also auf geographisch eingegrenzte Gebiete beschränkt sein soll, auch das ist nicht der Fall
und das hatten wir ja hier auch im Vorfeld zu der ganzen äh Frage immer wieder und immer wieder. Das ist eben hier keine Ausnahmen oder keine Schutzregelungen gibt für,
sogenannte Berufsgeheimnisträger, das bezieht sich halt unter anderem und vor allem natürlich auch auf Journalisten oder auch Ärzte.
Oder auch Beratungsgruppen, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie,
greifend die Definition von Berufsgeheimnisträgern ist, aber es gibt das halt.
Ähm der Heiko Maas würde natürlich sagen, dass es all das gibt ähm allerdings ähm immer nur nachher, ne? Also du hast eine Beschränkung auf ähm.
Schwere Straftaten.
Aber halt erst nachdem die Daten gesammelt sind. Mhm.
Genau, du hast äh äh du hast eine du hast einen Schutz, der äh Berufsgeheimnis trägt,
Träger beim Zugriff. Ähm.
Also es wird zwar alles gespeichert, aber sie meinen, ja, aber man darf ja nicht alles abfragen. Und aber es ist,
sagen nicht, das ist ja genau die Grundkritik an der Vorratsdatenspeicherung der Gegner, die halt immer sagen, na ja, wenn alles gespeichert wird, dann sind einfach die Begehrlichkeiten
immer groß und die äh gebotene Kontrolle lässt sich in dem Sinne nicht umsetzen und,
in dem Moment, wo halt ein Elefant im Raum ist, äh, kann er dann sozusagen sich auch alles,
bemächtigen, was äh ihm gerade so in den Kram passt.
Das hat jetzt erstmal noch keine direkten Folgen, ne? Das ist jetzt erstmal nur äh.
Aussage.
Politischen Diskurs durchaus äh interessant.
Exakt. Ebenfalls interessant für den äh politischen Diskurs ist das Europol natürlich gerne äh sagt du, dass die VDS geht so nicht. Wir brauchen da noch ein paar Daten mehr.
Weil es ja reicht ja alles noch gar nicht aus.
Die haben sich, die beklagen sich spezifisch über ein Problem ähm über das sogenannte,
Was heißt Carria Greatnot.
Genau, das sollte man mal erklären.
Also nat heißt, wenn ich das richtig.
Ja Network Dustans Lation. Also das ist sozusagen das
allen Geräten, die dahinter angeschlossen sind, Zugang zum Netz zu geben, obwohl man eigentlich nur eine einzige Adresse zugeteil,
die bekommt man nur deshalb zugeteilt, weil eben Adressen knapp sind. Hier das
also explizit auf das alte IP äh System, IPV vier Adressen, das was sozusagen,
Ja, von Anfang an in diesem Internet verwendet wurde. Mittlerweile gibt's ja diese Transition auf dem neuen Adressbereich, der dieses Problem so nicht hat. Da es aber heutzutage
eben schon, ja, dass diese Umstellung auf IPV sechs ist halt im vollen Gange und deswegen,
und um nach außen hin dann entsprechend äh auch noch mit dem Rest der Welt kommunizieren zu können,
werden diese Nutz eben nicht mehr von dem Heimrauter durchgeführt, sondern eben vom kompletten Netzwerk.
Auch, ja? Also ähm bei uns ist.
Nur aber auch zunehmendem Wasser.
Um das nochmal zu zu sagen, also mein, wenn ich jetzt meinen Computer frage, welche IP-Adresse hast du denn, ja, dann sag,
ich hab hundertzweiundneunzig, hundertachtundsechzig, dreiundzwanzig neunundneunzig,
dass.
Jetzt hast du die rausgegeben.
Jetzt habe ich sie rausgegeben. Das ist nämlich eine RFC neunzehn achtzehn Adresse, also eine lokale,
lokale Adresse, die ich in Tims Netzwerk habe
Und wenn ich dann aber jetzt eine Seite aufrufe im Internet und mir von dieser Seite sagen lasse, welche IP habe ich denn, dann sagte, du hast eine IP, die mit einundneunzig zweiunddreißig anfängt,
Ähm das ist die, diese IP-Adresse hat quasi Tims Fritzbox und wenn der Tim jetzt auf die gleiche Seite geht
dann wird der auch diese IP-Adresse angezeigt bekommen, das heißt ähm nach draußen sieht erstmal alles was aus Tims Netzwerk kommt,
Wie eine IP-Adresse aus. Und genau das Gleiche macht jetzt der ähm in der Regel machen das Mobilfunkanbieter.
Aber auch andere Netzanbieter, weil es eben gar nicht mehr so viele Vier-Adressen gibt,
Das wiederum führt dazu.
Wenn jetzt ähm.
Wenn jetzt also von einer IP-Adresse ungemach ausgeht.
Und die Polizei sagt, hör mal, wer hatte denn dieser IP-Adresse zu diesem Zeitpunkt.
Und sagen, das sind die Leute, die diese IP-Adresse zu diesem Zeitpunkt hatten. Und das, das ist natürlich jetzt ein Problem, aus Sicht von Europol, weil die wollen ja wissen, wer es genau war. Das heißt, die fordern nun eine Ausweitung.
Und zwar auf äh und ist nicht wie nicht unbedingt so einfach. Die wollen, dass die die Portübersetzungen,
mitgegeben werden, weil was was natürlich im Prinzip macht, ist den,
Server weiß ja quasi zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
intern anhand der Ports, über die die sprechen. Also der Kunde sagt, hey, ich will mal da und da hin
und sendet quasi ein von einem bestimmten Source zu einem gewissen Destination Port und im NAT wird das einfach nochmal umgeworfen und alles auf einer IP-Adresse gemercht und dann hat er quasi ein Mepping,
hinter welchem seiner Source Ports sich welcher Kunde,
findet. Und diese Daten möchte Europol jetzt bitteschön auch gesammelt haben und so das.
Ähm am Ende die der die Trennung wieder,
wäre, dass man zumindest die Fritzbox findet von Tim,
und nicht zwanzig.
Oder mehr?
Oder mehr, ja. Also die beklagen sich jetzt gerade über Karrieregrade,
heißt, wenn die sich darüber beschweren, dass sie das natürlich rege,
auch dann nutzen. Und an dieses Problem inzwischen,
geraten sind. Also während äh die Wissenschaftler noch sagen, das geht sowieso alles nicht, haben wir wenig zu erwarten, Europol da, die eine entsprechende Ausweitung.
Äh der der gesammelten Daten verlangen, um auch wirklich jeden wieder einzeln identifizieren zu können.
Behörden, sondern die das FBI.
Ähm,
gerne mal auch an Daten rankommen von Kunden, unter anderem.
Von Google, nicht nur, aber da gab es halt äh entsprechende Anfragen. Konkret geht's hier um Zugriff auf die Daten von Kundendienst, nicht in Amerika sind oder die Diren, ich hab's nicht so ganz verstanden,
deren Daten nicht in Amerika gespeichert sind, sondern auf ausländischen Servern
wie zum Beispiel in Europa. Ich weiß nicht, wo Google äh überall Soldatencenter hat, aber es sind äh sicherlich schon einige.
Der.
Also Microsoft hatte ein ähnliches Urteil im letzten Jahr im Juli zwanzig sechzehn. Hm, für die,
Also die Frage des Serverstandortes und des Landes und der Juristik, den die der diese Server dann unterliegen ist für diese,
Cloud Anbieter natürlich enorm wichtig. Microsoft hat signifikant investiert,
in diese Deutschland Cloud, Europacloud oder was auch immer, ähm weil sie.
Ein ein Effekt gesehen haben, dass die das Deutsche ihre Daten nicht in die US-Cloud geben,
Die mussten also die haben Infrastruktur geschaffen, um zu sagen, hier
Gesetzgebung, kein Zugriff der NSA, ne? Das das unterliegt den hohen deutschen rechtlichen Standards, wir schaffen eine juristisch,
euch akzeptable Cloud, ja? Es gab ja immer wieder auch den, den Hinweis von Daten ähm
Datenschützern, die gesagt haben, also unter irgendwie Privacy schielt und was da alles für Scherze gibt,
nicht ernsthaft deutsche Daten.
Und ungefragt einfach in diese US-Clouds werfen.
Und da ähm waren war Microsofts signifikant daran interessiert, äh da dann eben für äh für Ordnung,
Berufungsgericht New York gesagt haben im Ausland gespeicherte Kommunikationsdaten müssen nicht an Strafverfolger ausgeliefert werden.
Ähm.
Dass äh genau, dann ging das FBI in Berufung und das Berufungsgericht New York hat gesagt, nee, komm, äh, egal. Das äh nehmen wir nicht an und damit war das eben rechtskräftig. Jetzt wollte das SBI Daten von Google-Nutzern
Und diese Daten sind auf ausländischen Servern und die wollten darauf zugreifen,
Spannend ist hier, dass ähm.
Google sagt.
Unsere Datenzentren schieben die ganze Zeit Daten hin und her und wir wissen hier und es die können auch fragmentiert sein. Also es kann irgendwie sein, die eine Hälfte liegt gerade in Deutschland, die andere Hälfte liegt gerade in den USA
und können wir euch leider nicht geben liebes FBI.
Und dieses äh dieses Urteil äh die oder dieser
wurde vor dem Amtsgericht Philadelphia verhandelt und das Amtsgericht Philip, er sagt
vor. Ähm
bevor es all diese Phänomene gab
und ähm da äh hat das äh FBI selbstverständlich Zugriff. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt die paradoxe Situation, dass es bei Google ein Urteil New Yorker Urteil gibt, äh bei bei Microsoft
New Yorker.
Urteil gibt, was auch geht nicht und für Google ein philadelphianisches Urteil gibt, das sagt jo.
Ein Amtsgericht ist auch sehr interessant. Ich äh habe das nur so mit,
Entscheidungen von lokalen Gerichten bezüglich Speicherorten und so weiter ist auch von daher etwas delikat als dass dieses Amtsgericht ja explizit auch für einen bestimmten Bereich zuständig sind.
Und ähm dass sie eben auch nicht mal eben ein äh ein Untersuchungs ähm
äh Untersuchungsbefehl äh bestätigen
der jetzt in einem anderen County ist, in dem sie eben nicht explizit zuständig sind. Das war schon ein Problem,
so Darknet, Servern, et cetera, Kinderpornoringe
die bei irgendwelchen Hostern sind, ja? Also es gab dann lokal die Anfrage hier IP-Adressen, da war das aber irgendwo anders in den USA sehr umstritten, ähm wie wie das sozusagen da läuft und hier wird halt dann eben auch noch vom Amtsgericht über ausländische Server
entschieden, also das scheint mir nicht so richtig das letzte,
Lied zu sein, was jetzt hier in dieser Messe gesungen wird.
Google hat auch schon gesagt, wir gehen im Berufung, also das Thema B.
Noch eine Weile verwalten, genau. Ein Thema, was uns äh offenbar nicht erhalten bleibt, ist die Auseinandersetzung zwischen dem Youtuber,
Tobis Tricks ist seine äh Webseite werden das hier vor, wie lange ist das jetzt her ein Jahr.
Ist wahrscheinlich schon lang nicht, ja.
Ist schon eine Weile her, berichtet. Die Auseinandersetzung war dadurch gekommen, dass er ein,
Video veröffentlicht hat, in dem er die Umgehung
Adblockersperre von Bild DE äh dokumentiert hat, also sprich Handlungsanweisungen gegeben hat, was man an seinem Computer einstellen muss, um äh nach wie vor Bildzeitungs äh Bild-Zeitung online äh zu lesen,
warum auch immer man das tun wollen würde, ja? Aber
dagegen ist Herr Springer vorgegangen, dann gab's halt einen entsprechenden,
eine Weigerung von ihm da eine Unterlassungserklärung zu unterschreiben, hat ein Crowdfunding gemacht
Da es aber ein ja Verwandtes, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man das nennt äh in der Rechtssprechung.
Inhaltlich absolut Verwandte.
Ähnliche Gerichtsauseinandersetzungen gab in äh Hamburg, wo Springer und EU sich ja äh seit einiger Zeit beklagen, also EU ist ja der Hersteller von diesem AdBlock Plus, um den es ja auch bei Tobi ging. Wurde der ganze Prozess nach Hamburg,
verwiesen. Nun ist das Hamburger Gericht ja dafür bekannt in Sachen Urheberrecht doch sehr nah an den Verlagen und so weiter zu sein.
Ohne ihn da jetzt irgendeine äh Parteiung so unterstellen zu wollen, aber es ist einfach so von der,
Von dem Ergebnis, was dort normalerweise erzielt wird, immer alles etwas knifflig. Ja und nun,
kam es zu einer Entscheidung und hier wurde Axel Springer.
Springer Verlag Recht gegeben und.
Tobi hat jetzt angekündigt, dass er es damit auch belassen sein wird, weil das Geld, was er bekommen hat, um diesen Prozess zu führen, ist aufgebraucht. Ich glaube, seine Nerven auch
und er hat jetzt keine Lust, an die Berufung zu gehen, akzeptiert das Ganze, hat damit natürlich auch mehr Kosten, kann im Prinzip auch noch von Bild nochmal von äh auf Schadensersatz verklagt werden
Weiß ich nicht, ob die das dann auch noch durchziehen. Ähm.
Na ja immer, also der der Gerichtsfall hatte so ein paar,
Also mit, dass das irgendwie äh dass es nach Hamburg ging, war ja schon mal ein bisschen ärgerlich und ähm eine weitere,
Wunder etwas Wundersames in diesem Prozess war, dass es kurz vor dem Prozessbeginn ähm ein weiteres Gutachten oder ein neues Gutachten eingereicht wurde vom Springer Verlag,
Das war irgendwie äh viele viele Seiten,
wo sie dann irgendwie versuchen, auf irgendwie zu erklären,
dass es äh Technik eine technisch wirksame Maßnahme ist, äh was äh Springer,
versucht mit diesem AdBlock Blocker. Denn äh wir erinnern uns, die Argumentation, warum sie das verbieten wollten, ist ja folgende.
Die Lizenz, die Lizenzbedingungen quasi. Unter denen,
Wer nun einen AdBlocker nutzt,
verletzt die den Wunsch des Urhebers, was die Bedingungen der Darbietung angehen.
Angeht und ein AdBlocker Blocker ist somit eine Maßnahme.
Zur Sicherstellung der Einhaltung der Lizenzbedingungen des Urhebers.
Diese ein ähnliche Argumentation gibt es bei den Kopierschutzen,
wo gesagt wird,
quasi ein Tool zur Umgehung des Kopierschutzes von DVDs,
darf nicht in äh Umlauf gebracht werden, weil der Kopierschutz eine legitime Maßnahme zur Durchsetzung des Interesse des Urhebers oder des Rechtseigners an dieser Stelle ist.
Interessant, dass man jetzt hier ein Video als Tool äh sehen könnte.
Das erst, aber das war jetzt erstmal der Streitpunkt. Jetzt kommt,
Springer und sagt, wir haben hier nur kurz vor Prozess gehen, werfen wir
weil sie nicht sechzig Seiten Gutachten in den Ring und sagen, haben wir übrigens auch noch hier, bitteschön.
Und das Gericht sagt, ah, alles klar, schönes Gutachten nehmen wir, äh nehmen wir mit auf in die im Prinzip Beweis
Mittelaufnahme. Und der Anwalt von Tobi sagt, na Moment, äh hier ich will einen Schriftsatznachlass, das heißt, ich will Zeit haben, mir das alles mich damit vertraut zu machen und darauf zu antworten
Und das äh Gericht sagt aber nah, nee, wir haben nicht mehr viel Zeit, weil eine der Beisitzerinnen unserer Kammer wechsel
und es kommt jetzt ein neuer Richter und dann müssten wir den neu einarbeiten. Wir wollen ja irgendwann auch mal hier zu Potte kommen. Also wir urteilen jetzt hier ab.
Und äh dann haben die geurteilt und jetzt eben die äh Begründung gegeben. Und die Begründung ist, sie sagen also erstens.
Springer hat ein Unterlassungsanspruch gegenüber diesem Tobi. Weil das, was er da verbreitet, ist etwas, was sie Geld kostet.
Zweitens sagen sie, der AdBlocker Blocker ist eine äh wirksame technische Schutzmaßnahme im Sinne der.
Begeht der Tobi eine verbotene Handlung im Sinne des Urheberrechts,
wenn er mittel verbreitet, die zur Umgehung der Schutzmaßnahme geeignet sind.
Und außerdem haftet er als Täter und dabei ist es unerheblich, ob er das, ob er gewerblich vorgeht oder als Hobbyist äh mit seinem äh kleinen YouTube-Kanal.
Und weiterhin vermuten sie, dass eine Wiederholungsgefahr besteht. Das heißt, sie haben den auf voller Breite,
die die Schuld und die Haftung gegeben und damit eben auch,
den Weg aufgemacht, dass Springer jetzt Schadensersatz von ihm fordern könnte,
ist eben die die Rechtslage,
'ne Berufung hätte ihn fünfzehntausend Euro gekostet und hatte relativ wenig Aussicht auf Erfolg und aus diesem Grunde macht er das jetzt nicht. Ähm.
Meine persönliche Einschätzung dazu ist, dass das ähm rechtlich.
Also korrekt und zu erwarten war dieses Urteil? Gleichzeitig halte ich aber dieses Recht an dieser Stelle für.
Mangelhaft beziehungsweise nicht akzeptabel, ja? Also man müsste um da jetzt nochmal sinnvoll Recht zu bekommen, müsste man wahrscheinlich.
Ausführliche Änderungen am Gesetz.
Vornehmen.
Bundesverfassungsger.
Oder so, ja. Denke ich auch nicht.
Das heißt das ist.
Unschön, dieses Urteil, aber dem geltenden Recht entsprechend.
Also vermutlich.
Ähm vielleicht findet sich ja irgendein äh findiger Anwalt, der sagt, nee, überhaupt nicht.
Muss dazu sagen, äh ich finde das ähm löblich, dass der Tobi sich da zumindest in die Schlach,
genauso gut kann ich das verstehen, dass er da jetzt an der Stelle die Segel streicht,
weil jetzt da nicht doch theoretisch noch irgendwo ein Funken Hoffnung äh wäre. Man muss einfach sehen, gerade für Leute, die das äh vielleicht nicht täglich machen,
Solche gerichtlichen Auseinandersetzungen, das ist einfach irgendwie, das ist so schon so eine Scheiße am Schuli, willst du einfach nicht haben.
Das nervt und das das ja, also wenn du wenn du jetzt nicht ohnehin mit solchen Dingen dich gerne befasst und irgendwie für gegen das Unrecht der Welt äh äh an Sturms an der Stelle,
Willst du es einfach irgendwann nur von Haken haben, hast aber auch keinen Bock, das die ganze Zeit im Internet dein Name steht und äh ja.
Ja vor allem wenn du äh in in so einer David Goliath Situation bis,
also der äh wenn wenn da irgendwie äh,
von Schadensersatz gegen den Springer Verlag die Rede ist, dann äh steht immer auch die Option im Raume,
dass du äh zu etwas verurteilt wirst, was dein äh was dich mehr oder weniger für den Rest deines Lebens ruiniert.
Und äh dass du da mit eine.
Anwalt, den er sehr lobt, äh auf einem relativ verlorenen Posten gehen, eine komplette Rechtsabteilung bist, äh die nichts anderes zu tun hat, als mit am Ende jeder Scheiße durchzukommen. Ja, die sind, das sind trainierte Leute ähm,
Gerade der Springer Verlag ist ja mit seiner sonstigen Tätigkeit die gesamte Zeit,
juristischen Auseinandersetzungen ausgesetzt, äh, in denen diese und hat eben entsprechend geschulte und geschärfte Anwälte für die
so etwas, wie man eben so ein sechzig Seitengutachten außer,
im letzten Moment äh aus dem Ärmel zu schütteln. Halt einfach zum Handwerk gehört und für die auch finanziell
problemlos zu leisten ist, ne? Ähm und mit den Leuten wird's natürlich keinen Stress haben.
Ja, nicht nur zu leisten ist, ist halt auch, dass der ganze Urheberrechtsbereich einfach etwas ist, worauf sie sich natürlich äh bevorzugt gerne und äh mit hoher Priorität draufstürzen. Also hier ist es einfach das äh Verhältnis äh des Kräfteverhältnisses einfach ganz klar
liegt da weit auseinander und deswegen können wir das alles nachvollziehen, wir nehmen das jetzt mal zur Kenntnis, wie es gelaufen ist, schauen wir mal, wie sich die Rechtslage in den nächsten Jahren in der Hinsicht,
wickelt.
Ja, eh, also ekelhaft, also der, der fahre Beigeschmack bleibt natürlich, dass er echt,
weiß nicht, ob sie das inzwischen geklärt hat, aber der äh gute Tobi äh,
hat ungefähr knapp vierhundert Euro zu wenig gespendet bekommen
Das heißt oder oder nicht zu wenig gespendet bekommen, dann gab's noch irgendwie eine Streitwerterhöhung von fünfzigtausend auf vierundfünfzigtausend oder irgendwelche solche Scherze auf jeden Fall letztendlich hat er gerade, muss er noch irgendwie,
knapp vierhundert Euro aus eigener Tasche zahlen. Äh, das ist natürlich.
Vorbehaltlich dieser Schadensersatzklage, die vielleicht eben auch noch auf.
Einer potenziellen Schadensklage so. Ich hoffe mal, dass der, dass der Springer Verlag ähm jetzt einfach auch mal,
Ruhe gibt, weil das der ihn tatsächlich sinnvoll äh nennenswerten finanziellen Schaden zugefügt hat,
halte ich für unsinnig, insofern den darauf jetzt auch noch zu verklagen wäre eine.
Wäre wirklich,
Kanonen auf Spatzen zu schießen und einfach nur eine ähm,
Ein Akt der Unbarmherzigkeit an dieser Stelle. Insofern kann man hoffen, dass der Springer Verlag sich da mal äh,
zusammenreist, ähm aber prinzipiell hätte ich erstmal das Anliegen, dass der Tobi nicht auf diesen vierhundert Euro sitzen bleibt. Also ähm den Mut, den der da bewiesen hat,
den sollte man zumindest damit entlohnen, dass er nicht auch noch die den finanziellen Schaden am Ende trägt,
den er da jetzt hat, der hat genug Nerven äh investiert und genug gelitten. Das hm,
Merkt man auch, dass er sagt, er will das jetzt auch einfach will, will seine Familie damit nicht weiter belastet sehen,
Und insofern denke ich, die Familie sollte auch nicht mit diesen knapp vierhundert Euro belastet werden und ähm da könnt ihr,
nochmal auf die Links klicken und schauen, äh welche Möglichkeiten es da gibt, ihn vielleicht nochmal.
Die die Anerkennung und Ehre zu erweisen, die die ihm dafür diesen Einsatz gebührt.
Gut, äh, kommen wir zu einem anderen interessanten Streitfall. Wir haben ja schon äh häufiger hier über die Auswirkungen des Informationsfreiheits äh Gesetzes äh ähm
gesprochen, seitdem es dieses Gesetz gibt, gibt's halt die Möglichkeit, ähm von bürokratischen Prozessen innerhalb,
Was nicht explizit als streng geheim äh oder sonst wie geheim markiert ist natürlich.
Und für diese Informationsfreiheitsauskünfte.
Aber unter Umständen Gebühren an. Nun ist die Praxis so,
dass äh nicht nur Gebühren erhoben werden, sondern teilweise auch,
Auslagen, wie das so schön heißt. Ähm angeführt werden von den Behörden, um Auskünfte zu machen, gerade bei erhöhten Datenmengen,
müssen dann auf einmal unglaublich viele Kopien erstellt werden und das ist ja alles total teuer, wie wir wissen
und man kriegt dann halt so äh Preise wie im Copyshop äh ähm berechnet,
Was natürlich dazu führt, dass diese Anfragen eben sehr teuer werden und man hat schon immer so ein bisschen den Eindruck.
Dass das äh ein vorgeschobenes Argument ist.
Ja jetzt äh gab's eine entsprechende Klage gegen diese äh Praxis.
Zwei Journalisten, Daniel Drepper, Niklas Schenk, ich weiß nicht genau, was die machen, weißt du das?
Ich ich komme mir aus diesem Korrektivumfeld nee ja doch genau Daniel Drepper ist auch bei bei Korrektiv und ähm.
Also politische Journalisten, genau
diese Schiene da. Genau und es gab eine Anfrage beim Bundesinnenministerium, die zwar dann entsprechend auch Informationen geliefert hat, aber ähm eben einen Gebühren äh Bescheid hatte. Höhe von fünfzehntausend äh,
ja? Obwohl ich mir durchaus vorstellen könnte, dass die Kopien nie haben wollten, sonst ist es ganz anders. Einfach auf einen Stick bekommen hätten.
Und aber die äh das äh das Bundesverwaltungsgericht dieser Fall
ging ebenfalls Bundesverwaltungsgericht und das Bundesverwaltungsgericht sagt, nee, die die zweitausendeinhundertvierundachtzig Euro fünfunddreißig für Kopien, die kriegen die auf jeden Fall zurück.
Genau. Gebühren werden jetzt erstmal so kann man kann man erheben,
aber eben keine Auslagen.
Ähm also jetzt müssen wir gucken, was was heißt das, ne? Also wenn du äh,
die müssen jetzt kostenlos kopieren, wenn der Kopierer da steht, die können dir aber offenbar diese anderen Kosten, die da ja auch noch Teil des äh der Auseinandersetzung machen. Die können sie ja durchaus äh in Rechnung stellen, wenn sie da welche haben. Ähm,
Für die sie eine eine Rechtsgrundlage haben, ja? Also die können, wenn sie irgendwelche zusätzlichen Aufwände haben oder sowas, die jetzt über das Kopieren von vorhandenen Daten hinausgehen, dann können sie offenbar argumentieren und können diese Gebühren auch verlangen, aber
wunderschön, da ist deswegen auch hier nochmal der Hinweis. Wenn für Auskunftsanfragen an Behördengebühren anfallen, die irgendwie die vertretbar sind und für die sie begründen können und die recht rechtmäßig sind, dann übernimmt Wikimedia die Kosten,
wenn die Ergebnisse äh der Wikipedia oder Wikidata zugute kommen. Ähm.
So im Sinne von, dass die eine Interesse an dem äh an der Information haben oder wenn das dann in Gipidia landet.
Wenn die, wenn die davon profitieren, ich glaube nicht, dass die dann irgendwie so eine strenge Regel dafür ziehen. Aber wenn jetzt zum Beispiel diese wissenschaftlichen,
äh Gutachten des Bundes,
die die Gutachten des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestages, der ja mal vor kurzem alle frei,
profitieren wir
das Projekt Wikipedia und unser Vereinszweck davon, wenn das passiert und wenn das eben mit Gebühren ähm verbunden ist, die irgendwie rechtmäßig sind, äh dann äh sind wir natürlich als Trägerverein auch bereit, diese zu erstatten. Da gibt's also ein Angebot für
für Deutschland und äh auch für Österreich. Und äh außerdem äh die äh die strategischen,
für die ist das Projekt äh Transparenz Klagen gibt,
Transparenzklagen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, eine ähm Zusammenarbeit zwischen,
Nollege Foundation und der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte, ja, siehst du mal, habe ich richtig in Erinnerung.
Ähm, wo also Streit ne die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte haben wir dazu genüge vorgestellt, ob Knollid Foundation ist das die Trägerorganisation für unter anderem,
fragt den Staat und Jugend hackt und solche Dinge, auch da hatten wir die Maria Reimer schon zu Gast, alles keine,
keine neuen. Also man kann sagen für die Informationsfreiheit ist gerade,
Gibt es gerade sehr viel Unterstützung, ja? Also einerseits können sie dir die Kopikkosten nicht mehr in Rechnung stellen, andererseits gibt es Unterstützung für die Gebühren von äh Wikimedia und wenn irgendwo mal ein Rechtsfall zu klären ist, der sinnvoll zu fechten ist, hast du sogar noch,
Transparenz klagen.
Und den ganzen Verklag den Startstyle, der an dieser Stelle auch nochmal ähm,
hier zu empfehlen ist, da gab es nämlich den dreiunddreißig C drei Vortrag zu,
mit einer wunderbaren musikalischen Dark Darbietung,
bekannt und berüchtigt, dass sie ähm.
Ihre Vorträge mit musikalischen Darbietungen ähm anreichern.
Und äh dieses Mal war es äh Feuer frei.
Was dort da geboten wurde, denn Feuer, FO, IA, Freedom ON, Information Act, ähm,
Da sieht man in welche Richtung das geht und da gab's eben eine eine sehr schöne musikalische Darbietung, die äh man
sich keinesfalls entgehen lassen sollte. Der Suchbegriff auf Media CCCD an dieser Stelle Tim ist Arne Semsrott.
Stefan Wehrmeier hat nur am Ende mitgesungen.
So, so, das wird also nicht korrekt vermerkt, ja?
Irren ist staatlich, heißt der Vortrag. Zehn Jahre Informationsfreiheitsgesetz mit großartiger musikalischer Darbietung am Ende.
Somit sind wir auch am Ende der Sendung und können noch eine Terminempfehlung äh abgeben.
Mit fröhlichen Grüßen von,
äh wo es um Diskurs, Musik und,
geht das Event,
am nächsten kommt, sagt Thomas, als persönliche Meinung.
Und dieses Jahr unter anderem mit dabei sind äh Constanze Kurz, Julia Reder und Max Schrems. Ähm,
Ansonsten wollten wir nochmal kurz darauf hinweisen, dass ihr euch ruhig mal melden könnt mit Konferenzen, Ausstellungen und sonstigen, die für unsere Zuhörerschaft interessant sein könnten,
Ähm.
Genau, also es kann.
Also kann, aber muss nicht unbedingt jetzt unmittelbar netzpolitischen Bezug haben, wenn's denen nicht,
hat, dann fragt euch einfach, ist das sozusagen für die zu erwartende Hörerschaft hier vielleicht auch aus sonstigen Gründen,
Interessant ne, einfach her damit. Wohlformatierte E-Mails bevorzugt und äh mit klarer Aussage.
Ja, ich meine eine Pressemitteilung schreibt man ja auch so, dass der Journalist keine Arbeit hat und sie möglichst eins zu eins direkt abdrucken kann, sodass da überhaupt gar keine Arbeit anfällt, ja.
Ich nehme die auch formlos entgegen. Der äh der entscheidende.
Bald hier wird noch journalistisch gearbeitet. Wir den Ethus.
Der entscheidende Punkt ist, ist das Event sollte zumindest, sage ich mal, so ein bisschen.
Überregionale Bedeutung vielleicht haben. Also,
sag mal die Schwelle, dass jemand aus einer anderen Stadt dahin fährt, die sollte,
will ich jetzt mal die Seite überschritten werden, weil wir äh kämen halt am wir kämen hier aus der Sendung nicht mehr raus, wenn wir jetzt wirklich jede äh jede Kryptoparty erwähnen, äh die irgendwo stattfindet, obwohl ich,
Gleichzeitig der Meinung bin, dass das natürlich wichtig ist, diesen Events zur Öffentlichkeit zu verhelfen. Insofern kann das sein, dass wir da auch meine der äh eine Ausnahme äh machen, um die Regeln zu bestätigen. Aber.
Genau, deckt euch Highlights aus. Und kommuniziert sie. Ja, das äh führt uns an, das berühmte Ende der Sendung. Ganz ohne Elefant.
Der, ja, was, ganz ohne Elefant haben wir die Sendung überstand.
Möchtest du nächstes Mal wieder Elefant haben.
Reicht erstmal.
Ich habe übrigens äh habe ich auch schon irgendwie auf Twitter bekannt gegeben. Ich reise ja eigentlich jährlich in die USA.
Äh nee, ich habe mir, nee, das äh ich habe mir einen Direktflug äh organisiert. Das war tatsächlich meine Sorge und ich habe den so gebucht, dass ich nicht ähm.
In den USA bin. Vor allem habe wo habe ich das gehört genau bei ähm bei methodisch Inkorrec,
Reinhard Rempford ist ja gerade in Mexiko und der ist nämlich über Dellis oder sowas.
Ja und der musste ja oder Atlanta oder so. Das war aber bestimmt schlimm, oder?
Nee, sowas mache ich nicht. Ja, der musste in, der musste halt raus und wieder rein, dann bist du stundenlang beschäftigt,
hatte aber offenbar Glück an der an der Einreise, hatte da einen netten, ähm habe ich, muss ich sagen, auch bisher immer äh,
gehabt. Ich habe ein bei der Einreise in den USA bin ich nie äh bedrängt oder schlecht behandelt worden.
Wo wo man dann auch drüber nachdenkt, ist das jetzt ein gutes oder ein schlechtes Zeichen? Ähm.
Aber ich,
mir das auf äh wenn ich nicht unbedingt muss, werde ich dieses Land erstmal nicht mehr bereisen.
Dann zu treffen in äh Mexiko.
Und äh dann an dieser Stelle kann ich dann noch danken dem Jens, dem Kai, der Marina, dem Robert und einer unbekannten Person und die unbekannten Personen sind wie immer äh gebeten. Wenn sie, möchten sich äh,
bei mir zu melden und äh eine Nennung nachzuholen.
In diesem Sinne wünschen wir euch eine gute Woche trotz allem und ähm ja munter bleiben.
Also ich wollte noch ganz kurz hier mit diesem unbekannten unbekannte Person, ne?
Das kann tatsächlich mal passieren. Also wenn man, wenn man, ich hab mir letztens selber was gekauft von meinem Wunschzettel.
Und dann stand da irgendwie so was hier, sie schenken das ja, was was machen wir jetzt?
Dann kam am Ende dieses Paket an und ich mache das auf, legt einen Zettel drin,
ähm und steht dran, ein Gruß von Linus Neumann Doppelpunkt im Amazon Versandkarton, versenden ausgewählt.
Keine Ahnung was ich da gemacht habe, aber ich möchte sagen, dieses dieses Interface dabei, Amazon scheint irgendwie ein bisschen verwirrend zu sein, weil selbst ein erfahrener Internetsurfer
und Online-Shopper wie ich da offenbar sich selber sich selber mit den Worten grüßen lässt im Karton versenden ausgewählt.